let's move to this from the
post-millennial and educator at El
Dorado High School in Placentia
California was captured on video giving
students explicit instructions during
class on how to have pleasure during
anal sex
and where to find sex toys that will
stimulate the prostate gland
the video posted to Instagram account
EDH s caught lacking as the Instagram
Instagram account shows the educator
sitting atop a desk in front of a
classroom full of students
discussing why anal sex is pleasurable
for gay men we do have that video which
is
like I I feel uncomfortable playing this
video because it's so disgusting and
it's really quite explicit
um
but this is what
is being talked about in schools this is
being presented to kids at schools
and so we have to face it and here it is
where the prostate is so you don't have
to go inside the booty hole you can
actually just push on
and that stimulates the prostate gland
as well and that all they apparently
really like that
um but yeah so that's why for male and
male
anal sex is still very pleasurable
because of the fact that it hits the it
hits the prostate and there's a lot of
nerve endings in your booty as well so
the girls the G-Spot prostate they're
the equivalent to each other but
apparently that's why if you ever see
like
I think target has them now sex toys if
you go to Target seriously if you go to
Target and go where the tampons and pads
are they have they just look like a
little box but if you open up there's
like a velcro front to the Box you open
it up and then bam sex toy and uh you'll
see them
and so that's why when you look at the
the toys a lot of them look like this
uh you know I can keep I can keep saying
it and sound like a broken record but I
will say it every time that that woman
should be in prison like that's a that
should be a prison sentence
um
and that's what that's what I want to
start hearing you know that's the next
step the next phase
uh for it or it should be for
republicans
there's been a real effort to ban this
kind of discussion from classrooms which
is good
but next we need to start saying that
that the the teachers who engage in this
Behavior
are sexual predators
um because that's what that's what that
is like let's just call it what it is
this is not simply an inappropriate
conversation for the school system which
it is
this is that you are you are praying
sexually on kids
uh
and you need to go to jail for that
takes a special kind of company to want
to partner with my show I say a lot of
things that make a lot of people angry
and this tends to scare off advertisers
that's uh just part of the bargain
that's why I'm so grateful for partners
like pure talk who stand behind me and
my show no matter the consequences they
might face that takes real courage in
their part it really does pure talk
shares my values which is why we've made
them the official cell phone wireless
partner of the daily wire that's not the
only reason though Pure Talk offers the
most Dependable 5G Network in the US I
use it myself it's a great product so
you're not just buying it because you're
supporting the cause you're buying that
but also it's a great product and a
great service their plan their plans are
top tier but at a fraction of the cost
of ATT Verizon or T-Mobile you can get
unlimited text talk and unlimited data
with a mobile hotspot for just 55 a
month you vote with how you spend your
money so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you instead
go to puretalk.com Welsh they'll get
great coverage and you'll save while
you're doing it when you go to
puretalk.com Welsh you'll save an
additional 50 off your first month
because they act actually value you if
you can imagine that that's puretalk.com
Walsh Pure Talk Wireless for Americans
by Americans
we will know that some semblance of
Sanity has been restored to this country
when we see a video like that but
instead of just cutting off it ends with
police officers walking into that room
putting that disgusting
predator in handcuffs
and carting her out of the room
and then throwing her into a jail cell
throwing her into a cage like an animal
is what she deserves
that's when we know that sand that when
when we see that that's going to be our
uh our sign that sanity has has really
made a comeback
you know we're making some progress I
think sanity's trying
to make a comeback but that's how we
know it will it will have a
that it really The Comeback has has
started I suppose
uh yeah the other the other interesting
thing about that video
is you listen to the class
like they're not even paying attention
nor should they be this is a useless on
top of being disgusting and wrong
um and predatory uh to be talking about
this in the classroom it's also
completely useless and pointless on top
of all that it's got nothing to do with
any kind of academic subject that they
need to be learning about and the kids
don't they're not even paying attention
they're bored by it
so good for them I'm glad they're not
paying attention
but what does that tell you
you know I I think at least when I went
to school
and even when I you know compre
so-called comprehensive sex ed and this
is a concept that that really originates
as we talked about it was a woman with
Alfred Kinsey uh degenerate pedophile
and it really starts with him and he's
someone who very much wanted to
sexualize children and so as long as
there has been comprehensive sex
education in the schools and there has
been for decades there has been an
effort in the schools to sexualize
children because that's what
comprehensive sex ed is all about
uh and we had comprehensive sex ed when
I was a kid in school so there were
plenty of inappropriate conversations
going on not nothing nothing to that
extent
and I think back to when I was in high
school
if we had a teacher sitting up there
talking about that we would be shocked
uh there'd be a lot of like nervous
laughter and people would be shocked and
you know that would be probably stunned
silence I think also
but these kids are bored they're just
like carrying on other side
conversations and I think what that
tells us is that they're so used to
hearing this kind of stuff from their
teachers that it's not even surprising
to them
they're not even laughing at how awkward
and inappropriate this is
as kids probably would have 20 years ago
when I was in high school
for them it's just another day at the
office this is another day in the
classroom
and that's uh maybe the most disturbing
thing about it in fact
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed